Hey, I'm Shawn Evans, host of hot ones, and I'm here to answer the internet.
Um.
Would you rather,
you have your girlfriend's hair or she has your hair?
That is an easy example. My,
my girlfriend has just beautiful, beautiful, healthy,
flowing hair. If I could get that, uh, Lauren's hair,
I'd trade in a second. And mine, I got a mess over here.
If she had this I'm out, when you're drunk,
is it better to get laid or have the ideal drunk meal?
Good question. You know, the conventional thing is to say,
get laid and I'm trying to make a case for the perfect meal.
And I can't, the answer is get laid.
All right. If you were in an open field with an aluminum baseball bat,
how many ten-year-olds with bike helmets?
Could you take down before they got you?
Those kids would be in trouble 10 years old. I'm trying to think.
What's that like fourth grade, third, fourth grade.
I probably take out at least eight or nine ten-year-olds with helmets.
I think you're selling yourself short. You think, I mean,
you did not have triple digits. Come on.
You can think you can take out a hundred kids.
You know how exhausting that would be washed your watch to
be gassed after five swings? No, if they're coming from all sides,
one jumps on your back, like another one climbs on him. I'm down to my knees.
Just trying to swing that thing. And it's over.
Do you think there are more porn stars or murderers in the world?
Uh, you know,
I think there have to be more murderers.
I don't know how many porn stars are there, like 400, 500 more than that.
Yeah, it depends on what you qualify. I'm going to say I'm gonna,
I'm going to treat porn.
Like it's a professional sports league and I'm gonna say that you have
400 to 700 porn stars.
In which case you have way more murders. And uh, you know,
and I know this I've been listening to a lot of true crime podcasts lately.
Yeah. And now I feel like they're around every corner, so murders. All right.
The next question is the Labatt blue light featured question.
The episode, uh, if you've made it this far,
we probably don't need my instruction, but that would be.
If you had to eat one human body part, what would it be?
Put whatever sauce you want on it. Put a, yeah, like a nice,
I think, you know, you want to eat a butt cheek.
I feel like that's the closest thing to like a,
like a fatty sort of chicken breasts, the shape of it. I could get, I could,
I could jump that in my head.
If I'm looking at a foot or from looking at a hand,
it's like the fish that they serve you, and it's still just a fish. I can't,
I can't, uh, I can't do that. I can't do that.
Or the pig on a roast on the spit roast and stuff. It's too real for me.
It's too real for me. But, uh, I can,
I can separate myself from a butt cheek and I actually think a human buttcheek
probably, you know, prepared correctly.
Not.
Bad. If you were taken hostage five years ago,
what would surprise you most about the world today? Five years ago,
that puts us in 2015, uh,
before you had, uh, w the idea that, uh,
Uber Lyft,
that just some random person is rolling up and they've been deputized
through an app to be a taxi driver. What the hell here in New York,
I talked to these taxi drivers all the time and say to get the medallion,
they had to hand over like a decades worth of paperwork,
and it cost them $80,000. And they got two, three guys split in this cab up,
and it's like such a difficult, hard business. And then Lyft, Uber,
just like a random college student getting some hours like any at the
car. It's ridiculous. Yeah. Now I don't even think they like emission test.
These cars is cat hair all over the back seat. It's ridiculous.
You have a choice between a sum of money and world peace.
How much money would it take for you to give up the world? Peace.
Here's good guy, Sean, coming to the cause. Here's the way I look at it. Like,
honestly, the way I grew up, even, you know,
experienced some success lately in my, you know,
your eyes widened to certain things and possibilities and things that you never
thought possible. Maybe they are vastly. I can't spend a hundred million.
You can give me a hundred million dollars. I can't,
I don't think I can spend it.
I don't think I'd feel good about spending more than that.
I'd I'd have issues with that. So if you dropped off a hundred million dollars,
that's the most I could ever spend in my life. So the question is,
would I take $100 million or would I take world peace?
And let me tell you something, I'd take world peace.
Yeah.
Way more than a hundred minute piece. You know,
how much know much world pieces worth.
What movie most recently made you cry?
It was not that long ago. I saw, um,
Florida project.
I don't know if you've seen Florida project and cover your ears spoilers. Uh,
but when she knocks at the door at the end and her friend opens it up and she
has the tears and they hold each other's hands and they go to Disneyland
together, Disney world together wa it was crazy.
And I is my, you know, I'm just, I've got it down. Both eyes dripping,
falling off of my chin. And it had been so long since I cried.
I didn't even know if I could anymore.
And then Florida.
Project last movie that made me cry. Hey, I needed something.
Hey, if you haven't already got it. Get yourself a copy of answer the internet,
the card game it's available right now in the link in the bio,
or you can get a Barstool sports, Walmart, Amazon,
or Spencer gifts play along with us.